night is a bittersweet night for the
cast of Modern Family the 22 time Emmy
award-winning show signs off tonight
after 11 seasons and I am joined by Ty
Burrell right now to talk about it are
you emotional it's funny because of all
of the everything else has happened in
the world it made it feel like that was
sort of like 10 years ago that we
wrapped the show yep gonna lose a
toenail
there goes there though season well get
your tissue boxes ready because
tonight's one-hour documentary a modern
farewell and the two-part series finale
that follows are going to be tearjerkers
just like this last day on set was for
the tight-knit TV family
[Music]
it's the first time in my life as an
actor that the director came out and had
to say like could you guys cry less how
hard was it at the end to say goodbye to
these things yeah it was difficult that
last take you know we were fortunate
enough with our production that the last
scene of Modern Family was also the last
scene we ever shot and looking around at
all those kids who had spent their whole
childhood with us uh it was very hard
very very emotional I start to get
worked up about it now when I was on set
with the cast you were during your last
week of filming I asked you if you're
gonna steal anything yeah
yep taking anything home I took a plaque
from the wall that of Phil Dunphy's we
at one of his real estate achievements
and I put it up on my office wall so
that you know it looks like I achieved
something in my life no I didn't take
anything at all I wanted to just not be
that oh no no yeah I took a few things
actually these guys are more givers than
takers their newest projects helping out
those in need during the kovat 19 crisis
tip your server is a program I'm trying
to raise money for all of the unemployed
workers in the food and beverage
industry we bought through harvesters
there which is a feeding America
organization we purchased two hundred
thousand meals for families there in
Kansas City meanwhile Eric tells us a
Modern Family spin-off with Cam and
Mitchell could be in the works but he's
already found a way to reunite with
another family member you filled in for
Heidi on America's Got Talent it was
like it's Sophia okay with it I mean
it's her brand new job she may not want
to see me yet and I left they're so
excited and so bummed because it's not
my job I'm so happy I get to do that and
I want to go back now immediately
[Music]